[موسيقى]
تعود انا من صغر هؤلاء مع ابائي واجدادي
ان ناتي الى كاس هذا المسجد ليصلي فيه
الصلوات الخمس كنا ناتي الى هنا ولا نزال
محافظين وانا اشجع احفادي ان يكونوا معي
في هذه خاصه في ايام الجمعه
[موسيقى]
بدات الناس تتوافد على المسجد الابراهيمي
وخاصه في صلاه الفجر وقامت بالعائلات غربه
الى الله سبحانه وتعالى باحضار الحلويات
واحضار الطعام فتعائله صغير منشجع كل
ابنائنا وابناء محافظه الخليل ومن خارج
الخليل بنشجع الكل انه يلبي النداء ننزل
على الحرم فكره من لب الاولاد
والنسوان والشباب والشيوخ كلها بننبيها
نتيجه تصلي في صلاه فجر العظيم
[موسيقى]
بعد مصدرة الحرم عدد المصلين في لا يتجاوز
اكثر من
20 اغلق الحرم لمده سته شهور بعد اغلاق
سته شهور فتره طويله من السنوات هجره
اعتباره عمل على احياء هذه
المبادرات من قبل العائلات وحمايه الحرم
الابراهيمي اليوم احنا اللي بنشوفه الحمد
لله رب العالمين اعداد الاف المصلين بقدوا
الصلاه
[موسيقى]